une file d'attenté comme on en a
rarement vu devant l'atelier de ces
artisans du 19e arrondissement
tous ces gens patientent pour récupérer
un masque de protection en temps normal
dans cet atelier
florence et bérangère fabrique et
commercialise des gourdes éco
responsable mais depuis le 7 avril
dernier ce sont des masques qui tombent
de leur machine à coudre des masques
fabriqués à partir de dons de tissus
tout commence là donc à par exemple
c'est un tissu que qu'une personne du
voisinage nous a donné ça s'appelle
awacs c'est du 100% coton que nous avons
lavés à 60 degrés on l'a repassé et
après j'ai un patron que j'aime qu'on a
préparé
donc ça c'est pour petite taille pour
les enfants et ça c'est pour les adultes
on les coupe comme ça voilà donc il ya
quelques étapes au passage et cetera
pour aboutir à ça
ça c'est un carré c'est la découpe que
j'ai fait avec l'épi
voilà donc double tissu et une fois que
cette assemblée
on arrive à ce modèle qui est là une
petite révolution pour les deux artisans
qui s'est imposé comme une évidence
il faut savoir qu'on a mis dans un
quartier populaire et les maisons pas
beaucoup de fous il manque d'information
etc
donc on essaye de les aider c'est paris
qui vont aller acheter des masques à 30
euros ou je ne sais où
sur le net donc voilà notre ça fait
partie de notre vie que d'aider son
prochain au mieux qu'on peut en tout
elles sont sept à venir ici bénévolement
16h30 les grilles s'ouvrent un par un
les gens rentrent et s'est mis à 17 ans
la fille de florence qui assure la
distribution
une centaine de masques distribués ici
tous les jours les gens donnent en
moyenne 3 euros pour un masque
de quoi permettre aux deux fans
d'acheter les cordons qui serviront à
leur conception ou encore de payer
l'électricité de leurs ateliers
mais pour le reste et notamment l'avenir
de leur entreprise
c'est un gros point d'interrogation
c'est vrai qu'avec le coc vide toutes
nos commandes toutes nos commandes alors
qu'on avait travaillé dur pour se
relever de la crise
les jaunes ont été annulés c'est le plus
de la moitié du chiffre d'affaires de
l'année qui disparaît donc effectivement
les reports de loyer ce sera pas
suffisant si on nous allume si on
n'annule pas les factures
ça suffira pas à nous sortir de là
bérengère florence et toutes ces petites
mains bienveillantes vont continuer de
coudre des masques ici six jours sur
sept jusqu'à nouvel ordre
en attendant de savoir de quoi l'avenir
sera fait